When we visualize data, it's usually a lot
easier to draw conclusions. And we can see a
clear upward trend in the relationship between hours slept
and temporal memory. Based on this data, we can
say that in general, the more you sleep
the better your temporal memory score. This isn't to
say though that sleep causes a higher temporal memory
score. This is just the trend that we can
see from this data. We don't really
know if a higher temporal memory score translates
to a better test result. So we can't
say this second option. This third option is
the opposite of the relationship we see here.
And we definitely do see an upward trend
in this relationship. We'll get more into visualizing
data later. But for now, the point is,
data comes in all forms. As raw data, or visualized,
or in certain numbers that summarize the data. We should make good
decisions on what methods we should use to draw sound conclusions from our data.